[Music]
three two one action
hey guys welcome back top the record
where we talk about whatever we want
whoa think the quietest catch that's
work what is he doing over there I've
been doing this all day and it was like
pristine and I'm like I'm gonna put
these away but you didn't clean the
flutes yeah and do a good job like a dog
didn't find them for like half a day oh
[ __ ] go excited again yeah no I could
have isn't better everybody loves it
everybody loves me everybody loves it
yeah they love it cuz they're not
sitting here
you just got sensitive ears I'm sitting
here and I love it it's because whatever
I do is magnified because you gotta sit
up here that's true you know I always
see as big ears as why she's taking more
sounds coming in that's why she can't
yell my ears were um what's it called
what's the word insecurity mark and any
security of mine before like years ago
and she many years ago authorizer
years that's pretty good years and years
ago
what do you think my insecurities are
none you middle it no I I just don't
know what they are because they're
buried so even if it hurts me I don't
know what it is you know what you know
what I found out one was one was how I
squeeze lime don't [ __ ] talk about
how I squeal ah hahaha it's like I'm
there right now I'm so scared for just
okay so so she's criticizing the way
your squeeze lime and then you're like
don't [ __ ] talk about the way I
squeeze lime right yeah we got an
argument
thank you squeeze it funny and he does
like this he likes to do this while he's
yelling what are you doing I squeezed a
little bit of lime and I had like two
drops and then I ate something and then
she was making fun of me and I got hurt
but he doesn't know his sensitivities
until someone says it until I realize
how stupid that was
but you realize that until 48 hours
later probably God you are my dad I
swear what was your response to that I
just I was just hurt and I was like
leave me alone I'm a squeeze lime the
way I want to do cuz it's my life that's
like you sugar cane story but that makes
sense
okay everybody knows this just doubted
you right she doubted me yeah and I
think that that holds true to all
relationships when the woman doesn't
have your back and she doubts
Dreamwave it goes both ways well yeah
you you want him to support your dreams
no matter how crazy it is right yeah you
don't have to laugh at your dreams it's
just it's just that we didn't know each
other in the relationship she didn't
know how creative I was right really
creative so she didn't know if I was
joking or not Joe and that's what hurt
my cue she [ __ ] laughed in my face
because you said you wanted to open a
sugarcane farm right I want it I was
sure I was looking at um sugar cane
crunching devices she's like why are you
gonna get that and I'm like because I'm
gonna guess your came for him and then I
actually ordered she what she doesn't
know I ordered a stock of sugar cane to
plant which I did have in my backyard
that didn't go through all the way what
other reason how picture you get your
Jess and for example you're on like just
getting this and all of a sudden Joseph
says randomly I'm gonna open a sugarcane
farm and then she laughs and most of us
do that at a lot of your random sayings
but you don't know that it hurts my
feelings later
that's why I'm getting it I do [ __ ] like
that like I saw someone making stickers
and I was like I won't make stickers so
then I started making stickers and then
like you know I do thing and then Steve
calls me out on it and I'm like why
don't I just come home one day and I'm
like what the [ __ ] are you doing and she
has a sticker printer now and she's just
printing stickers and this is why I say
I live in a [ __ ] sick on cuz like
this is the episode where my wife
becomes a sticker maker and you gotta be
a more of a supportive husband that [ __ ]
I am we talkin about
well you like what to not call it out
for what it is and laugh with her I
gotta do all this cuz I know how she
feels
I know the page let's go Joe you wanna
go I know that pain over your worst
[ __ ] enemy dude let's go all right
let's go because I got her back on that
when you come in and someone's doing the
most random [ __ ] like when you told me
like you're like Jess you told Jess
while you're moving like I gotta get a
piano right now and then she's like
[ __ ] like what the [ __ ] are you
talking about and you're like you're
such a hater hey my dreams see to her
where which is where I'm at I was
walking into the most random [ __ ] ever
you don't know that we've been thinking
about it for like months and oh [ __ ]
both of that I'm not with you while
you're on your flag on a piano by the
way exactly dude we don't know what's
going on me and Jess both it's like I
don't know what's going on I just come
in and she's doing some random ass [ __ ]
that's man you you you guys jump to
conclusions you got a ass you have a
conversation when we're communicating
here like hey today I was checking out
nose researching sticker making today
[ __ ] and there's no way you're
telling just like hey for a while now
I've been thinking about getting a piano
while you're thinking about getting a
piano you didn't do that you're sprung
another one day hey I'm gonna get a
[ __ ] piano she's like we're moving
thank you very much cuz it's a part of
the furniture yeah that's true
mm-hmm that's very true you could make
your aesthetic around the piano has been
in heaven if you realize I'm making
stickers I'll be like oh hell yeah I
make me one
I'll walk away make sure you get a
[ __ ] one with the rainbow on my face
all right I'm done see nothing would
ever get done if we were lived in a
house together like the crazy siblings
yeah we are like significant other to be
that parent that grounds us crying in
the room and neither problem with you
and Jess you guys are too damn real you
live in a drink the [ __ ] kool-aid and
live in a delusional world but we are
the [ __ ] we are just like you are or you
guys are random people we're pretty like
grounded people last week he interrupted
me tell me this about this on my life is
right what a moon meditation is well I
still don't know once you put your
attentions out and you think about them
really hard you light a candle and then
you like you know you hold like whatever
rock of the once it is like for 20
minutes and then he came in and like the
middle of it about some stupid question
oh no he interrupted the [ __ ]
channeling I picture you connecting to
the moon attended now you got a recent
it has you been connecting and now Steve
comes in it breaks it apart sure I
thought I almost could be a millionaire
this month but not gonna happen
cult-like [ __ ] I've ever heard him thank
you motoki thank you I'll hold the
roster Oh she holds a rocket up [ __ ]
month is vibing with ya you doing chance
to think that would be ridiculous you
know what I think you know what it is
we it's like I know Pope placebos exists
right but I know that they also cure
things they work so I'm just trying to
make that work
so if I have a belief in something in
its delusional as [ __ ] just let me be
because I might be curing my own cancer
right now that's true
who knows but what if it's really funny
and and then we can
do it behind my back goddamn it not to
my face I can't
it's like means you can't I know it's
really funny but I want to laugh about
it with you later after I'm not in Italy
that's what I'm saying
see don't [ __ ] up the vibes while I'm
living in the dreaming maybe he got his
own vibe I can picture Steve the whole
time before you interrupted you my vibes
is he has his own office he's gonna be
showing for 30 minutes getting prepared
for sex time with you but the AC you
scheduled it with me yeah talk to my
sister dude you got you guys got the the
Joe table and we need the Stephen Jess
table that's true you got thought we got
a point of view and then this is the
moderator do you guys live in both sides
honestly I really could but where do you
live you are you the dream killer or the
killer killers dude just walks in one
day and you're wearing a [ __ ] giraffe
costume she's like you want a draft
rusty with the [ __ ] done and then
you're like you hate my dreams when
you're in the zone you're in a different
world okay just picture it as you're in
a different realm at that moment and
that can't be unbroken most you know
improv right so you don't want to be the
you don't want to be the note and ER no
true and I'm not no I'm not I'm a yes
and therefore sure yeah but but you have
to tell me what the bid is so that I can
be with you on the bit and how cuz what
you're doing is yes and you're stupid
well that's not what I want no he thinks
it's funny
he'd like him once he's like calm wife
yes but he does break it where I'm like
I don't even realize I'm doing a sitcom
wife they like when I had a grasshopper
yes
I remember I wake up one day and now
Mickey has a pack rats off her how much
I pick her she picked me right I'm just
a straight man in a sitcom and so is
Jess and we're trying to navigate our
own [ __ ] crazy lives but each day is
an episode right that's pretty funny
yeah the sticky show is like what
grasshopper I already got cats and a lot
of plants like and I talked to my plants
to it's a lot of them this so and the
grasshopper would not leave she likes me
a lot
dude imagine imagine being Jess and
Joe's like making some [ __ ] right and
and he's cutting alive and she's like
hot so funny the way you got mad because
he holds a fork silly and and so you got
mad at that sure I can hold a fork like
a caveman but I think it's funny too
like did you like let's then yes
so sometimes yeah if it gets repetitive
I'm like I'm holding the fork yeah yeah
weird colder just give me some damn time
maybe in three months I'll realize how
stupid it was yeah three months yeah I
realize this stupid in the moment but I
still want to do it and be in my moment
yes you know my life is like the avatar
where I go back and forth from the human
life to the blue world but then just
imagine it's in the same body but it's
just different times but you know just
doesn't know if you're a blue one or a
regular one
let's see motoki you just laughed at
that and that means you said yes and
it's stupid he says funny [ __ ] and then
you laugh at it he's like oh this guy
thinks I'm stupid
you're like just came out of nowhere
there's no winning which one which one
are you
motoki I'm with Steve I'm a practical
baby like that's what you look like to
thank you all right
you're an artist and just just wait
you're gonna you're gonna notice one day
that something's gonna happen you'll be
like oh my god my jeans being killed and
you're gonna be like oh [ __ ] that hurts
I feel like so every test of taking
their say I'm 50/50 their left brain
right brain right but like it's just
more fun on that other side with the
sticker making you know it's so I'm like
I don't like my dream killer side that
is she's so boring and practical and
like trying to protect me and like
trying to make sure I'm secure and stuff
and I'm just like it's just really
boring and it's way more fun on the
other side okay and by the way this is
this has not been criticism of you I
love that about you I said it all the
time I wouldn't change anything about
you cuz I like that I usually go the
most crazy when I feel like I'm being
the most practical like it's a balance
oh no we just did our taxes book I could
get out of this for sure that's why I
can tell you about the 14 so she can
feel normal
yeah mm-hmm I'm like you though yeah
I've been looking for a piano for a
really long time and I tell Christine
all the time she's like yeah let's go do
it and then she's like no we shouldn't
wish to save money we have a baby and
that sounds pretty practical to me
you're walking her through the journey
you're Longaberger yeah see joke
randomly Springs it on you and drops a
piano on your [ __ ] head and then he's
like why do you hate me that's true but
I feel we've all had our impulse buys
you know what I mean like I've bought I
bought a couch when I was drunk it was
the same thing that where I had seen
this couch for years like so you you
kind of like let it linger yeah yeah I
was drinking and I saw this sale like
that couch was $100 less than it
normally is and that's like [ __ ] I
ordered it but I didn't tell Steve any
of that you think you just get over
sitcom wife one day or the couch this
all came out in that bed episode it's
titled when she drunk ordered a couch
but see exactly that's what that's what
idea was what's more and I loved it yeah
it's fun it's fun
what's more absurd it is six or seven
years you're thinking about that couch
and it's only $100 off [ __ ] yeah
I thought about it when I didn't have
money to buy cabbage and then think
couch over that amount of period must be
a good calories it's still there there
yeah it's a blue velvet couch I get
compliments all and on all the time did
I fit in living room now yeah yeah
probably sat on it I like your couches
it wasn't my office and now it's in the
living room cuz we moved houses and now
that's a great buy she's great how about
that because I thought of it while sober
but then I bought it while drunk drunk
mind speaks sober heart and I never said
one word to [ __ ] about that couch either
I just walked in and I was like Oh naked
dump bought a couch okay that's true so
that means I appreciate junk Nicki cuz I
probably sat on that couch yeah see you
see that you see that have you guys ever
had any like bad drunk buys me yeah well
I always buy Facebook ad products no I
tell you a bad drunk by is buying more
alcohol great bye it ends up poorly I
don't know what that feels like
I don't drink one time you drink up [ __ ]
the pillow we heard about that yeah I
was in junior high yeah oh my god who
even supplied the alcohol I have friends
in high school
oh well be nice how did they get they
stole it or got it from somebody or
whatever it was Jose Cuervo and we
shotgunned Bud Lights oh man cracked it
with the key and drank it and I did a
couple of beers and some tequila shots
and then I was on the driveway puking
yeah and then went home and [ __ ] a
pillow [ __ ] the [ __ ] out of that pillow
had my mom showered me down pissing in a
trash can
I was in big trouble did you ever get
that commercial where you showed your
nipples no sorry I mean you know I
showed my nipples for no reason but do
you have very tiny nipples I feel like
you would have fair that small ones it's
like pepperoni nipples to be oh really
George nipples maybe it's a Japanese
thing yeah I got pretty big ones it's
like this big that is pretty big
do your shirt no yeah yeah but maybe
poking through oh I'm going Osaka over
oh yeah maybe Lobos ah yeah yeah it's
been fun Universal Studios Universal
what cuz we're there a couple extra days
after the thing they film there huh it's
apartment it's the park that well but
Studios they have this yeah they do
actually obviously there's a brand new
but the studio I have all the hangers at
Universal Studios you go do with that
tram ride that's what they have here I
don't know if it's the same over there
so there's just you know Studios theme
in Orlando do they film there I thought
they did I think they used to film
Nickelodeon shows there but then they
don't anymore
yeah they gutted that whole thing man I
would see the commercials when I was a
kid like Nickelodeon Orlando I got to go
and I went to double dare live and then
they didn't pick me and I was like [ __ ]
each other cuz dude to be there live and
did not get picked is like [ __ ] sucks
I even had mark summers like walk up to
me and he like pick the kid like just
next like dad little back behind me and
I was like and then I went to double
dare alive when it was in my area in
Virginia and I saw you get all these
opportunities dude because I used to
live across the street from George Mason
University and so they used to come
there and you could get tickets really
cheap as a local it was time and so yeah
I saw mark summers up close for the
first time and I was like he's [ __ ]
home he's like under natural light and
shinny like whiskers and shikha's he had
been on the road he did the how it's
made show after that I liked it when I
first started watching it cuz I'm like
cool I'm really curious to know how
these certain things are made and I
started making like some random Masek no
one gives a [ __ ] things and I'm like why
you know a youtuber does double dare now
oh yeah she's in here
did she host it she hosts it now she has
her own midnight show or something
tonight show oh sorry yeah that's racist
that is [ __ ] up yeah Wow
I even think about that actually thing
you're right they are they aiming
they're both Indian oh I don't even
think about that I didn't know that I
thought she was latina and Lily see was
in she was black at first yeah I
honestly just thought she was white I
had no idea you thought Liza yeah Koshu
I don't know what I don't know like
Mediterranean white yeah some [ __ ] like
that yeah I thought she was like Italian
of some [ __ ] Steve isn't series I don't
I don't I do all the [ __ ] dude keV
was here earlier and he's like I'm black
and I'm like what he's like yeah I am
yeah I forget that justice white
sometimes and she forgets that she is
just because she's around so many Asians
that happens to me too I forget about
your Mexicans well now that I think
about it like I don't think I'm any
other race but like I forget yourself
you know like I don't know cuz I don't
speak Spanish anymore back before
meeting Casey I used to like every other
word was in Spanish and now I try to
speak in Spanish and my tongue just it's
not used to it anymore it's you did well
in Mexico when we all went on the girls
trip or at least something so he's like
I sounded like you yeah to my untrained
ear know I sound really like grunge Oh
what's oh yeah my god that's bad one
eight yeah just le American born like
it's not America oh good when I look cuz
I lived in Mexico for one year when I
was 15 years old I was not born there I
remember well mourn there hey it's so
much we thought you were it's a branding
thing come on a party game and then they
thought that I was born in Mexico and
I'm like come on okay anyway I like to
picture you as Dora Explorer mm-hmm I
never had that haircut
I did when I wasn't ready can we I was
living there they thought that I was
actually like born in Mexico people the
other because I met my Spanish was so
good and now I can't do it well cuz she
was like the country I'm born in and but
she always talks about being Mexican so
did you sit there in Japan
we talked about it Japanese cool so you
know how to read write and all that
stuff I went only for like kindergarten
to first grade some oh [ __ ] you just an
American boy yeah pretty much are you
and your homework this our benefit
Japanese yeah fine I'm Japanese cause it
sounds like similar to Spanish so I can
walk in Party imperative thank you
horchata a certain universal you should
go to the studio ghibli
newsmen Park yeah yeah you've seen cut
it spirited away cut it I'm having it
cut this [ __ ] this mother what happened
y'all never seen a studio jib ok so then
they're distributed by disney here in
the united states but it's like the
biggest animation comes a stream it for
some reason yeah though I'm worried
about the laws the cat yeah it worked
kind of blue cat bunny
I know what he looks like I've never
seen the thing they ask you this though
Spirited Away
was in theaters in the United States and
I viewed that poster out too right yes
beer I see I know the face Ponyo funny I
heard of that
didn't see it fun fact the reason that
the animation category exists in Oscars
is because it studio ghibli
yep because they story wise
[ __ ] crazy well beautiful I've
cried during so many digital films oh
great about the fireflies that should
[ __ ] get you fear like [ __ ]
day I crime watching reality TV so I
know
[Music]
[Music]